voters in New Hampshire will head to the
polls starting at midnight tonight for
tomorrow's primary candidates spent
yesterday making closing arguments all
around the state they're all vying for a
top spot in what appears to be a very
tight race former Vice President Joe
Biden hopes to boost his chances ahead
of the boat he joins us now from Nashua
New Hampshire with we're checking in to
see how his campaign is going I watched
you all weekend mr. vice president you
said look it's an uphill battle it
doesn't look good
what struck me about that is most
candidates never say it doesn't look
good they put on the face and say I'm
going to win even though they know
they're not but you were out there
candid about your chances in New
Hampshire why well because I viewed the
beginning of this campaign being the
first for the first two caucuses in the
first two primaries nothing's going to
happen until we get down to we're a
place that and around the country where
there's much more diversity and you know
and you're always behind the eight ball
when you're running in New Hampshire if
you have two people from in the
neighboring state so but I feel good
about what we're doing up Houston we're
having a problem moment moment fourth in
Iowa maybe fourth in New Hampshire it's
not a time to regroup and reassess I
don't thinks it Gail look no one has
ever won the nomination as a Democrat
without getting overwhelming support
from the Latino community and the in the
african-american community we're just
getting to the game here mr. vice
president it's also true that no one's
ever won the nomination after finishing
out of the top two in Iowa and also out
of the top two in New Hampshire which
according to polls is where you're
headed
so you're making an electability pitch
if voters from these two states are not
saying we want to elect this guy why
should the other voters out there listen
because the other voters out there
represent a significant portion of the
American people and they look like
America that's the reason why again look
nobody's ever we've never been in the
contest where we had a guy like the
president president sitting there and
everybody everybody everybody including
independents a lot of Republicans think
he has to go look we're just getting
going you got to get 1,900 delegates or
more and we're this is just getting
started and I've said that from the very
very beginning and I feel confident
about where we are we're raising money
for exam
well I just got a number of additional
endorsements the Black Caucus and
Michigan just endorsed me in this period
the number of the major unions the ibw
have endorsed me since I so III don't
see any diminution in national support
I'm still leading nationally and so the
idea that this is you know if you if you
come in third or fourth in the first two
primary or caucus in a primary that that
knocks you out of the box we're just
getting going but mr. vice president you
you appear to be bleeding support from
moderates particularly in our latest
poll - Pete Buddha judge in New
Hampshire you've stepped up attacking
him saying he's he's no Obama do you
think you've underestimated him indeed
you do you regret not attacking him more
directly sooner no look I was responding
to him saying that Obama and I didn't
we're part of the problem remember
everything he said up until now is that
we inherited this problem was
predictable we're in real trouble this
all came from the recent past and I'm
very proud of the work I did with Barack
I'm very proud of the work I did and
Hanlin Recovery Act nine hundred billion
dollars I'm very proud of bailing out
the automobile industry which I get
significant credit for I'm very proud of
the things we did and I just want to
make it clear that he's wrong about the
recent past eight years of Obama Biden
was a good eight years we got us out of
a ditch we got us out of a hole we were
moving forward but he talks about it
like it's all been a failure that's the
real responding to his attacks on the
failure of an administration which I
think did a damn good job you seem to be
saying that this raises actually I think
that yeah you seem to be saying that
this race is actually bigger than
politics I've heard you you're one of
the few I think that talks about the
moral center of this country what do you
mean by that what I mean by that is look
this is this goes beyond just whether a
Democrat can win this goes beyond
replacing a man that in fact is as has
just absolutely battered a soul this
country after those folks came out of
the fields gale and down in
Charlottesville I wrote an article for
the Atlantic magazine saying we're in
the battle for the soul of America
look what he's doing look at the budget
he just admitted he eviscerates Medicare
he eviscerates food stand
she goes after all the things that
affect the people that are the reason
why I'm running for office in the first
place and the way he talks to people he
belittles people he makes fun of them he
focuses on any infirmity they may have
as physical or otherwise this is not who
we are and think about this not a joke
how many times do you know people that
are friends of yours who have literally
when he comes on the air take their
children away from the television we are
in the battle for the soul of this
country we are not the country he makes
us out to be and it's hurting us
internationally and nationally this this
politics of division and I'm about
uniting the country bringing everyone
together Brown black poor wealthy
Democrat Republicans mr. vice president
the president's also been going after
your son and Lindsey Graham told CBS
News the Justice Department is vetting
information from Rudy Giuliani about
your son's work in Ukraine are you
concerned a federal investigation may be
already Giuliani federal investigation
are you are you concerned to go from
look III expect look I expect Trump to
do the same exact thing he's been doing
why has he been attacking me from
beginning why did he risk and he should
have been impeached why did he risk
getting convicted by going to a foreign
leader to say don't you have to give me
anything I'm Biden there's nothing to
get just tell me you're going to
investigate him so I can hurt him have
you ever seen a sitting president as
concerned about a single nominee and
trying to stop a nominee do you think do
you think your son is fair game here his
son or my son your son Hunter I don't
think I don't think our sons are fair
game at all no one has said he's done
anything wrong except the thug Rudy
Guiliani
come on Rudy Guiliani character witness
mr. vice president speaking speaking to
voters over the last two weeks many of
them brought up the fact that they
thought Hillary Clinton had baggage back
in 2016
some of them point to you and the
Ukraine issue and say true or not it's
baggage it's a political vulnerability
somebody who doesn't have that baggage
at current juncture is Mike Bloomberg
who is surging in some polls we've got a
CBS tracker poll that says 37% of voters
of democratic voters in New Hampshire
say they would consider Mike Bloomberg
so my question to you how concerned are
you about the rise of Bloomberg I'm not
concerned by the way the only baggies he
has is all that money man he's already
spent three hundred million dollars not
advertising money is a strength to money
is a strength to live we've raised about
a half a million dollars a day so your
campaign is not your campaign is not
running low on cash as some people are
reporting no it's not and he said not
not till today I hope you guys help it
out a little bit here all right mr. vice
president thank you very much we
appreciate it good luck campaigning
today thanks for having me I appreciate
it a bunch